next we have Brian Jacob he's the CTO
and the founder of data world he is a
leader in building large-scale consumer
internet systems and expert in data
integration solutions he has 20 years of
experience in academia and professional
experience spanning case western reserve
university trilogy amazon and most
recently building homeaway com so
welcome thank you thank you so yeah
thanks to a Wolfram for inviting me here
and it's it's really great to be able to
address this audience here you guys are
this is a really smart group of people
to get to get to address so I'm honored
thank you to build the web of linked
data we have to start by connecting the
people who are working with data I truly
believe we're going to build a global
web of knowledge and when I think of it
I think it's going to be like the
Starship Enterprise when jean-luc Picard
says computer and asks a question in
English and gets back an answer and you
see that today a little bit with Siri
with an echo but that's and all that
natural language processing that goes
into that is great it's amazing
technology but that's the keyboard
that's the interface the reason why you
have things like Wolfram Alpha that can
they can answer a much richer set of
questions and the reason why the future
is going to be the star trek computer is
because of the connected database that
sits behind it and the technology that's
going to build that already exists has
existed for years it's the same kind of
stuff that goes into a lot of a lot of
the Wolfram sweet it's the technology of
the Semantic Web and of link data back
in 2009 tim berners-lee came on the
stage at Ted and said we haven't got
data on
web as data and he went in to explain
what he means by that he defined what he
means by linked data for that audience
there it's fundamentally three things
one give a unique identifier to
everything that you're talking about it
specifically gives URLs to talk about
the entities in your in your data to
when you reference when you dereference
that URL give me back structured data in
a standard format that I can consume and
I can parse programmatically and three
represent the relationship between
entities as links between those URLs and
if everybody would just do that we would
have this global web of length data and
this was the quote he left the folks at
Ted with and you know this is a guy who
invented the web and he's basically
staying there in front of this audience
and saying guys this isn't really
anything yet this web of documents we've
created it's great it's reputable
together but the real power is actually
to come when we can actually get at the
underlying data in the same way so why
in 2016 7 years later are we you know
we've made some progress but there are
18 million open data sets on the web
today and practically none of it works
like this link data is all about getting
the network effect going with respect to
data so we all know how networks work if
the network is small the value to adding
your node to it is relatively small but
the cost of picking up on these
technologies can be really high and data
scientists and business analysts and
CIOs aren't necessarily that interested
in paying this cost when the value they
see is pretty low but as the network
gets larger that value starts to
increase and literally increases
exponentially the cost stays the same or
goes down and eventually you're going to
connect all this data together because
it would be foolish not to connect your
data to that resource and the biggest
richest organizations in the world and
the one percent of people working with
data they get this so why organizations
like
Google and Facebook based a huge
percentage of their are using out of
their infrastructure on this BBC almost
all of their syndication is based on
semantic web technology Goldman Sachs's
entire internal data warehouse is based
on RDF and that's that's true across a
huge swath of financial institutions
government institutions like the CAA who
are doing deep network analysis to
assess threats use this technology but
the problem is in 99 percent of the
people who are working with data aren't
aware this technology don't use it as
part of their day to day so I think
three things have to happen to start
getting that flywheel going and moving
us closer to a world where the where
we're actually building up this web of
linked data one we need to connect the
social networks of people actually
working with data together we need to
grow the data super connectors that can
help increase the number of connections
between data and we need to build a
bridge to link data so number one
building social network and I think the
social networks of people working with
data gardeners recent report tells us
that the self-service data preparation
industry is going to be a billion-dollar
industry by 2019 today data preparation
work building pipelines using Python and
pandas and our tools like spark a huge
number of commercial of commercial tools
the these are huge areas of investment
and interest today and that's only five
percent of the market three years from
now it's going to be at least 20 times
bigger but the vast majority of the work
that those folks are doing which is
extracting knowledge making sense of
data so that they can use it in to build
their data products and perform their
analyses is being kept in data silos or
worse just getting thrown away at the
end of every project linking data
together requires adding that knowledge
to data about how it relates to other
data sets but knowledge engineering is
generally being done formal knowledge
engineering is being done top down by
the one percent of people who actually
were actually focusing on that
technology most people are generating
csv s and Excel spreadsheets or
downloading from
data portals they're the words ontology
and taxonomy are not part of their
day-to-day vocabulary but they are
building these pipelines and they are
adding knowledge to data and we can
capture that and turn that into it and
turn that into linked knowledge if we
can blink the minds of all those people
together that can be the engine that can
start to actually build build the web of
linked data but that social network that
connection of people today needs to add
value to the people who are working with
data the way they work with it today
there are a set of common common
problems that everybody working with
data trying to perform analyses has i
call it the who what when where and why
of working with data first of all who
provided this data central to the
Semantic Web is the notion that anyone
can say anything about any topic what's
meant by this is just like on the on the
web today I can't prevent somebody from
publishing data that is false or
misleading or that I just don't like if
you have a web of linked data and
everyone can contribute to it you can't
you can't stop somebody from saying from
saying anything that they want to say
that's actually why you want to have
strong central strong standardized
identifiers for the things we're talking
about so that we can know that you and I
are talking about the same things even
what we're saying it what we're saying
is different just like on the web the
consumers in control here you can all
you you can get around this in a
decentralized way because you can
control the sources that you want to
pull your data from so you can only go
to a particular database that you know
the provenance of and you know that you
can trust and a social network to bring
more data people into the into the world
of data needs to give folks that same
sense of identity where they can attach
their work and and and align it with
their with with their identity and those
identities can form handles that can be
used in the rest of the context that
goes around data the conversations and
the and the chains of provenance ago
with data what is this data about
data needs context to be able to
understand what's what what's inside of
it a CSV without a data dictionary or
some amount of diction of some amount of
documentation isn't generally going to
be useful to you if you don't if you
don't have explicit knowledge of what's
inside of it working with people the way
they are today the way they're working
with data today means letting them put
textual descriptions attached PDF
documentation images videos whatever is
necessary to convey the meaning about
that data but turning that into linked
data means giving folks are the tools to
iteratively take that out of band
context and move it in band in a way
that it can actually help them get their
work done where did this data originate
and when did this data last change data
providence is something that everyone
working with data it needs to understand
it needs to work deal with even if they
don't really understand what that is or
call it back and the vast majority
people out there don't but they need
that you need to know what's the history
of this data you need to be able to deal
with the fact that this data might
change and I might have to and there
might be new additional facts added to a
data set you need to deal with the fact
that multiple datasets might have a
single point of origin and things branch
and end go down different paths and you
need to be able to externally link to a
particular version of a data set not
just the latest version but to a
particular arbitrary version of a data
set that you use to produce your
research and finally why should I use
this data there is so much data on the
web there and finding it digging through
google can be a real challenge how do I
know which data set I should use and why
if you do is data set a versus data set
B features like following another user
liking a data set or a query these are
casual fun features and you it's easy to
kind of dismiss them but really what
they are at scale in a platform where
users are actually able to work with
with data there an incredible mesh of
signals they can classify users in their
work they can help identify cohorts so
you can find the things that are most
relevant to you and
can help identify the data and the users
that are the biggest connectors that
that actually can help help you find
more sources of data number two growing
data super connectors in any network the
more highly connected nodes help grow
the network more quickly just like in a
network of people the people with more
connections are more likely to introduce
to people who would have never otherwise
met the same is true with with with data
sets on the length web today dbpedia is
probably the biggest super connector
it's a length data it's a length
database that's produced from a number
of sources but most notably by scraping
all the structured data that they can
extract from Wikipedia so that as people
are collaboratively editing Wikipedia
the data that they're that they're
entering that can be parsed out is
pulled in and made queryable and to
build the web link data we need to
foster these super connections we need
to make them more visible when we need
to go and we need to create more of them
most of the super conductors in data
actually don't exist today is linked
data the previous speaker was talking
about the American Community Survey the
ACS is produced every year by the US
Census Bureau it's a sampling of roughly
one percent of the population to give to
give you a relatively up-to-date slice
of changing demographics and it's
already a data super connector he
mentioned the top hundred direct users
there's thousands of people is a
community online of people who work
together to use this data resource it's
published today as a directory full of
CSV files and a textual data data
dictionary and it's a hugely valuable
data set but that data dictionary has a
lot of out-of-band information you
really kind of have to become an expert
in all the different ways that you slice
and dice and aggregate that data in
order to make a lot of sense of it so
one thing that we've been working on is
building a linked data model of the
American Community Survey we build a
fairly straightforward data pipeline we
it wrote a bunch of Python code that
takes that textual they
Dictionary generates a raw rdfs schema
we do a lot of manual work on that to
really get in there to understand the
understand the concepts it
straightforward knowledge engineering
data modeling work and we produce that
enhanced schema that describes the same
concepts that were built into the ends
of the data dictionary we then wrote
wrote a separate set of code that takes
that the raw CSV data itself converts
that into an rdf model we have a
pipeline that we use sparkle which is a
query language over already over RDF
data we wrote a pipeline of 75 sparkle
queries that iteratively takes chunks of
that ACS data and aligns it with the
with the concepts in that enhanced
schema so at the other end we have the
ACS enhanced data so the net of all this
is we took the raw ACS data which is a
bunch of CSVs and some text that you can
read that you can understand and you can
reach out to a community of people to
help you help you understand and turn it
into a linked data model where that
context from the data dictionary is
embedded in the in the data can be
queried alongside the data just as a
quick couple quick examples of what this
what this looks like in practice so this
is a snippet from the state code from
that data dictionary and every state
plus the District of Columbia is coated
with a two digit numeric code so that
you can read that text file and you can
know that I get it when this column says
11 that means DC and this is what this
is what the end the corresponding entry
in our enhanced schema looks like we've
defined a URL for that state we've given
to type information we've added
attributes like the abbreviation for DC
in the label for District of Columbia
that basically represents a knowledge
graph where the the state itself and the
values of all of those properties are
nodes in a graph and the edges of the
graph are labeled with the names of the
properties another very quick example
two boolean properties i pulled out from
the from the ACS data dictionary one
represents whether this whether a
housing unit has complete kitchen
facilities the other represents whether
the housing unit is a multi-generational
household the interesting thing the
reason I pulled these two examples out
is that in the first case one codes for
yes and two codes for no and in the
second case one codes for now and two
codes for yes in the enhanced model I've
defined two properties I've called the
has complete I've stated that these are
object properties I've said that their
domain is housing housing records I've
put the text label that describes what
the property is inside of inside of the
data itself and I've normalized these to
a boolean value so that the value is
either true or false this is all
relatively straightforward stuff and the
upshot of having gone through all of
that is that I can now write this
sparkle query it which is very
straightforward if you understand
sparkle like me and tens of other people
and not that straightforward if it's not
something you're that well versed in but
what's really interesting is that so
much that i can write this query which
is telling me how many Millennials there
are per state and i could slice that by
any of the other you know any of the
variables and dimensions in that in that
data but because i've now got this as a
linkedin data i can start to write
federated queries where i could join
this data directly against against
what's in dbpedia or against any other
data set that is represented in that as
an RTF model
so number three building a bridge to the
web of link data if the vast majority of
people are not linking their data
because they don't get enough value in
return for the cost of doing so or in
many more cases they aren't even they
don't even know what that means it's not
even on their radar then we need to
reach out to them with tools that make
sense to the way they're doing work
today and bring it and bring them to
that web so imagine as an example a data
scientist named Alicia she wants to
perform an analysis comparing crime
rates in the DC area versus median
household incomes so she goes to an open
open data portal and download the CSV
and she goes to the American Community
Survey and she grabs the CSV for the DC
data and she's a Python programmer so
she codes up for her her Python pipeline
that takes those CSVs and produces there
was a resulting projection across them
and now she can produce produce her
analysis and publish it and she's happy
and she's done but when she's done that
she's actually added some knowledge
about what's in that that open data data
csv that she pulled off of off of a
portal and what's in the ACS and that
knowledge in almost every case is just
lost no one else can benefit from that
having been done because out the other
end of that pipeline she produced her
analysis and the rest of that work is
getting thrown away
if we can bring all of the Alicia's on
the world all the data scientists
together and give give them a way to
communicate and give them a way to
preserve that that work for posterity
they can bring the document based way
they're looking at data today into the
to the system we can convert that to
link data and we give them the tools so
that the work that they're already doing
with the tools are already familiar with
are going to start to create those
connections and we can still allow allow
users to work with that data through the
same the same kind of abstractions
they're used to working with the same
tabular tabular data data structure
because ultimately the vast majority of
people data the people that data
professionals are working with is
tabular data and so the way we look at
tabular data in our systems and I think
as a way to bridge any data any data
professional to link data you can model
tabular data just like you can model any
other any other type of data tables can
be entities columns and variables can be
entities you can model observations of
variables as relationships between cases
which are which which are which are
entities and the value and the values in
in the cells of a table you can annotate
variables and columns and tables with
descriptive information with type
information with things like indexes
that can allow you to render the render
the data back to something resembling
its original format you can start to
layer data you can start to look look at
the fact that i've got a zip I've got a
zip code column and it's five and it's a
bunch of five string five digit numbers
as strings but really a zip code is a
thing it's an entity it's a concept it's
a thing that we should have a shared
taxonomy on so that everyone who is
slicing and dicing their data by zip
codes is slicing and dicing their data
by the same zip codes and those
represent relationships to entities a
lot of the common practices the data
scientists do
fits very well into this model as well
cleaning cleaning compacted data you
know the value 1 x 750 ml isn't
something I can do a lot with
computationally but if I know that that
represents I've got one 750 milliliter
bottle of wine I can now take that data
and I can do unit conversions that I can
do do computation on it and I can
combine it with other sources of data
the inverse of that I might often have
data that's been broken up so i might
have month day year columns and I'd like
to be able to combine that to a date
value so that i can do data rhythmic to
arithmetic to it the key here is people
do this kind of data cleansing all the
time they do it it isolated in local
context and they throw that they throw
that inside away the fact that these
values can be usefully combined to form
a date value is generally not retained
along along with a data set what you can
do is you can model this as a new
variable that becomes part of the data
set the function to produce that can
become part of the data set and this can
live with the data as context it can be
useful to the next person who comes
along one final example just thinking
about a common statistical operation
like binning variables when you're
bending a numerical variable what you're
really doing is you're defining a new
set of categories and you're allocating
cases cases of your variables to those
categories based on a numeric value
those categories are things they can
have a URL that can have a unique
identifier and you can attach attributes
to them so you could for example label
the categories you can define the
boundaries of it you could you could
even do some upfront statistical
analysis of the data so that you can
have pre computed statistics already
attached in a knowledge graph or
attached to the data so that when the
next Alicia comes to do her project and
she brings up her link to her linked
data version of the crime statistics
and makes the connection to the ACS data
and John another data scientist who's
working on a project to analyze the to
analyze the performance of schools in
the DC area to decide where he wants to
move to send his kids and he's done the
work to connect up to the ACS so that he
can break that down by household income
by racial demographics he can he can
make the connection that Jesus be great
if I could also look at those schools
and look at the look at the area's I'm
thinking about living broken down by
those crime statistics to build the web
of linked data we have to start by
connecting the people who are working
with data and I think if we can connect
the social networks of people working
with data grow the super connectors on
the web of linked data and build a
bridge from the way people are working
with data today to the way that we'd
like them to work by connecting their
data and applying knowledge to it then
we could actually build the web of link
knowledge not just for the one percent
of people who get it but for and with
the 99 percent of people working with
data who can help get it done thank you